the story is about a wealthy businessman
named Kim Min Kyu who suffers from a
strange disease whenever he gets in
physical contact with another human he
starts having terrible rashes on his
body followed by shortness of breath in
extreme cases he can even faint or die
Min Q's biggest wish is to have a
girlfriend but due to his illness he
can't approach women a likely excuse and
because of the same reason he has
isolated himself for 15 years in his
house his personal doctor Dr o is his
only confidante who has tried several
ways to find a cure but to no avail
hence one day he tells Min Kyu to accept
his solitary life and hands him a smart
watch that uses colors to monitor his
allergic condition blue is normal yellow
represents a mild reaction orange means
that minku's Airways are closing and red
means that he will die in minutes a
severity that he's never experienced one
day a genius scientist named Professor
Hong contacts Ming Q he reveals that he
along with his team is succeeded in
developing a highly intelligent robot
that is capable of helping Min Q with
his household course and since she's not
a human she will not cause any harm to
him the cost for this robot is 100
billion won 100 billion Min Q feels like
this is a scam but out of curiosity he
goes to the lab to meet with Professor
Hong and as soon as he reaches there he
is welcomed by a robot that looks
exactly like a beautiful woman she
introduces herself as Aji III a highly
Advanced AI robot created by Professor
Hong Min Q is stunned by her appearance
and when he touches her there is no
abnormal change in him excited by this
new discovery he immediately expresses
his desire to buy Aji 3 and even invests
funds in the project but first he wants
to test the robot tomorrow unfortunately
that night at the lab disaster strikes
one of Professor Hong's team members
clumsily spills a droplet of soda in Aji
3's core processor causing it to
short-circuit the professor and the rest
of the team are devastated as it may
take several days to repair the robot
and since their deal can be canceled if
Aji 3 is not delivered to Min Q the
following day Professor Wong is forced
to think of a new plan he remembers that
his ex-girlfriend ji ah who is revealed
to be the Prototype of the robot Aji III
since Wong built the robot exactly like
her he goes to meet her both of them
have an awkward reunion and realizing
that Gia is experiencing financial
difficulty he offers her a salary of 10
million won if she agrees to disguise
herself as Ashi 3 for one day Jia
doesn't want to do a favor for her ex
but since she's in dire need of money
she agrees to the offer following this
professor Wong takes Jia to his lab and
shows her the robot then all the
scientists team up and help her disguise
like Aji 3 they fit armor in her body
put a new wig on her head and even give
her contact lenses these lenses will
actually function as cameras which will
help the professor and his team monitor
everything via the real Aji 3 Robot they
can also send instructions which Gia
will receive from her lens in the form
of text or videos the next day Jia is
sent to Min Q's house as scheduled but
when he opens the Box she jumps back in
Surprise it turns out that she has met
him previously when she worked as a food
delivery girl the experience was very
bad as minky tried leaving without
paying her but in reality he was just
trying to avoid physical contact with
her a likely excuse taken aback Min Q
immediately calls the professor and
demands to know what's going on
fortunately the latter makes up a story
that Aji 3 has two modes operational and
friend mode operational mode is where
she acts professional while in friend
mode she acts more like a human the
robot is now in friend mode but it can
be changed to operational mode by
pressing the reset button the naive Min
Q immediately believes this and presses
the button behind the robot's neck to
reboot after Jia returns to normal Min Q
decides to conduct an intelligence test
on her just then the lab power gets cut
off resulting in Jia losing total
connection to the RG3 system now she has
to rely on herself but her IQ is only
94. at first Jia is asked to unlock a
box whose password can only be found by
solving a complex calculus within three
minutes obviously she doesn't know
calculus so she simply breaks the Box
open which takes him in Q by surprise
then she is asked to peel an egg without
using tools within 10 seconds having
worked in restaurants previously she
easily completes this task main Q is
really impressed so he praises the robot
for being smart and creative Jia who has
never been praised for being smart
gently Smiles meanwhile the lab
electricity also comes back on but when
they connect to jio's lenses they are
shocked to see her yelling at Min Q
she's accusing him of being a pervert it
turns out the Gia is outraged to find
him staring at her chest which he notes
is bigger than it was the day before he
wants to open her up to check the
battery pack and extends his hand to her
chest a likely excuse the professor
drops to his knees in horror and is
barely able to answer when minq phones
who are you trying to deceive right now
mnq demands but they're relieved when he
actually only accuses them of using
cheap batteries making RG3's chest swell
up honk stutters for a while and lies
that he simply upgraded RG3's battery
pack he also warns Min Q to not touch
her chest just don't do that after
hanging up minku proceeds to have his
medicine but he suddenly chokes he drops
on the floor and starts to convulse but
fortunately Gia helps him by patting his
back as Min Q comes back to his senses
he stares at the robot with astonishment
when he inquires why she helped him
without any orders Jia replies that she
can do many things after this the two
have physical contact for the first time
but surprisingly Min Q does not
experience any allergic reaction finally
at the end of the day Jia is brought
back to the lab Professor Hong scolds
her because she was almost exposed but
Gia is annoyed because she believes that
she did a good job frustrated that she
is never appreciated she storms out of
the place soon the professor receives
unpleasant news that the special part
they'd ordered for Aji 3's repair was
mistakenly sent to Africa and it is now
at least two weeks away to make matters
worse Min Q also calls him at that exact
moment and Reveals His desires to take
Aji 3 for a month he wants to uh deep
learn the robot and make it fully
functional according to his needs left
with no options the professor calls Gia
again and requests her to disguise as
the robot for some weeks this time he
Praises her and offers an even larger
sum because of which she agrees right
away then Professor Hong explains that
from now onwards until the real Aji 3 is
repaired Jia will have to work at the
mansion and every night she will be
returned to the lab for recharging
unfortunately the very next day at work
Jia experiences explosive diarrhea she
tries to hold it in but accidentally
farts confused Min Q asks what's that
sound to which the robot replies you
fart my master soon the smell spreads
around the house so she suggests that he
change clothes the gullible min-q
believes her since there's no one else
except them so he leaves taking
advantage of the opportunity Jia rushes
to the toilet to poop however Min Q
returns early and finds that the robot
is missing he looks for her all around
the house and eventually finds her
spraying his expensive perfume in the
toilet Jia pretends to be cleaning the
toilet but Min Q doesn't believe her
claiming that robots cannot touch water
however she lies that she is an advanced
AI who is adept at washing dishes when
Min Q is about to leave he finds the
jia's face is sweaty he tries to
approach her but accidentally steps on
some soap and slips Gia rushes to Min q
but instead of saving him she catches
the perfume instead sadly she lands
right on top of him hurting his ribs
because of her iron plate that evening
when Jia is cleaning she accidentally
knocks down the card castle that Min Q
is compiled for 15 years seeing this
event unfold Min Q screams in agony but
before he can say anything more Jia says
that her battery has reached five
percent and pretends to be in standby
mode he later meets the professor by
saying that he's frustrated with her
mistakes but the professor tells him to
give her more time to deep learn Min Q
agrees to give Aji 3 more time the next
day Min q lights up to see a visitor and
warns Jian not to come outside it is
real his first love however his
excitement soon turns to horror when
real touches his shoulder minky tries to
keep his face averted and manages to
hide his spreading rash from real he
then pretends to have an important
meeting and rushes back to the house
somehow he staggers to his off-limits
room and reaches for the antidote
syringe but since he is too weak he
fails to grab them by the time Gia finds
him menqius collapsed to the floor
struggling to breathe just then the
scene flashes back to when everything
was normal for him in Q back to the
times when he didn't have an allergy to
human touch little Min Q's parents cheer
him on as he builds his very first house
of cards when it topples down dad chases
away his disappointment with some cool
card tricks in another memory everyone
gathers for Min Q's birthday party on
the drive home the entire family plays
word games but unfortunately as Dad
rolls down his window one of the
birthday balloons gets in his face and
their car gets caught in the path of an
oncoming truck Min Q next wakes up in
the hospital sobbing for his parents
both of whom were killed in the crash
I'll never look at balloons the same way
again during the day several relatives
visit him and try to become his legal
guardian the main motive is to inherit
his parents money but when man Q enters
the bathroom and checks his pockets he
finds a mysterious message which reads
don't sign anything later that day a
friend of his named YouTube approaches
him and hands him an adoption paper
yutual mentions that his father sent him
and that it would be great if Min Q
could be his brother minky thinks for a
while and eventually signs the adoption
papers thrilled YouTube grips his
friend's hand to give him support but
when Min Q looks down he notices
yutual's hand turning into monstrous
claws terrified men Q runs away
screaming while strange blisters start
forming on his hands where YouTube
touched him after a while yutual returns
to his father and hands him over the
adoption papers saying that the task has
been completed but when the father goes
to the last page he sees son of a [ __ ]
written in place of Min Q's signature
with this he realizes that the kid
simply wants to be left alone elsewhere
little Min Q returns to his dark empty
mansion and from that day onwards he
lives away from other humans feeling
betrayed by everyone he starts despising
other humans hence resulting in the
allergy to make matters worse as he
grows up no one knows about his allergy
except his personal doctor back in the
present Min he you jolt awake with Gia
beside him he tells her that he was
dreaming of people stabbing him in the
back however he's surprised to find that
he's in totally normal condition with
not even a mark on him hence he squishes
jia's cheeks seemingly grateful that she
gave him the injection has their
relationship deepens Gian Min Q spend
more time together and get even closer
one day Min Q asks her to accompany him
on a date with rielle the date doesn't
go too well and as real stands to leave
she suggests that they shake hands as
friends reluctantly Min Q takes her hand
which results in his allergy kicking in
soon he starts having labored breathing
and by the time he grabs his syringe he
is caught in two minds whether to use it
or not as he is tired of his miserable
life just then his smart watch starts
beeping faster and he eventually drops
the syringe fortunately Gia arrives and
brings him to his senses she sits next
to him and when minku looks at her his
reaction lessens and the monitor returns
to normal it appears as if he is
completely recovered even without the
syringe shortly after the two decide to
return back to the apartment but when
they are turning a corner Min Kyu
accidentally collides with a gardener
and falls down the latter immediately
grabs him and Q to check if he's all
right but surprisingly the allergies
don't kick in seeing this he tries to
test himself by joining large crowds
something he hasn't done in 15 years
later as the two venture out a child
bumpsman cues hand but again nothing
happens then the two join a crowd to
watch an outdoor performance where Min Q
jumps when the person next to him grabs
his hand for the wave a check of his
monitor shows that all is well as a
result minku's eyes fill with tears and
he softly says I'm finally cured
following this he walks to a quiet spot
and calls his personal doctor Dr o but
as he is tearfully confessing that his
allergy is gone a passerby bumps into
him causing his monitor to beep
voraciously meanwhile Jia starts looking
from in Q and when the two meet the
latter's pulse slows down and his rashes
start to disappear Min Q looks at her in
amazement and when the couple blocks his
view his symptoms return When Dr o asks
if there's anybody nearby minku admits
someone is here when I see someone the
rashes go away and when I don't see
someone the rashes come back however as
Gia smiles and waves Min Q tearfully
admits it's not a person after hanging
up the call minku Embraces Jia and tells
her it was because you were by my side
he promises to buy the world's longest
lasting batteries for her and even goes
on to say stay with me forever until I
die you are now my most precious
treasure as Gia stares in disbelief the
nearby crowd starts cheering for the two
prompting Min Q to kiss her on the
forehead no ring though cheap bastard
back home Min Q insists to Dr o that
even though he had contact with many
people he is perfectly fine he then
stands in front of his full-length
mirrors while he holds up the phone to
verify his claim doctoro is amazed that
for the first time in several years Min
Q doesn't require medication after human
contacts he clarifies that it was
because of the robot that's been with
Min Q for the past 10 days and calls it
a miracle then he tells menq to list
everything that happened since the robot
appeared so that they can figure out how
he was here third over the course of the
next few days several experiments are
conducted all of them point out that
minky will be fine with humans as long
as the robot GI is with him hence he
takes her with him whenever he wants to
meet somebody and considers her the most
valuable asset that he owns in the
meantime the Aji 3 Robot is finally
repaired it can function normally but
will require some time to adapt and make
the transition smooth Professor Han
claims that he will need some more days
before Ashi 3 deep learns and is ready
Jia who has started getting used to her
new life is sad about the news one day
Min Q takes Gia to a fancy restaurant
but makes her sit alone at a separate
table then he warmly receives real and
her father as the three interact a
clearly upset Jia looks on after a while
when Min Q comes to collector she
ignores his hand and leaves on her own
this goes on for a while minku is safe
only when Jia is around but one day
everything changes when he is alone Min
Q pulls into a gas station and opens his
trunk where credit cards and cash are at
the ready when the attendant Returns His
card he brush against Min Q's finger but
the latter is too distracted to notice
and simply drives away however after
just a few minutes he realizes that he
touched the attendant's hand and checks
himself for a rash surprisingly Min Q
finds nothing and his monitor also shows
that he's normal even though he's alone
so he arranges a meeting with his
personal doctor on reaching the hospital
Min Q hugs a speechless doctor o and
thanks him for his hard work the last 15
years indicating that he has finally
been cured completely after he calms
down the doctor inquires if something
made him happy and Min Q answers that he
finally understands love as expected
doctorow assumes that Min Q is talking
about real So He suggests that he also
thank Aji 3 he then tells Min Kyu that
he can send ashitri away now explaining
that Min Q became attached to the robot
because she was his first friend in 15
years but now that he's cured completely
he can get more happiness from an
attachment made to a human Min Q
protests that ig3 made him happy but Dr
o calls it an illusion he wants Min Q to
experience the touch of someone he truly
lives that evening a depressed men cue
approaches Professor Hong and reveals
that he is in love with the robot Aji 3
Hong finds it understandable that Min Q
has become obsessed with the first
friend he made in 15 years the one who
is also responsible for his cure Min Q
then confides that Aji 3 makes him feel
alive but Professor Wong reminds him
that they're talking about a robot which
was pre-programmed hearing this minku
admits that he is going crazy and with
teary eyes he begs the professor for a
solution the following day Wong comes to
Min q and tells him that there's one way
he proposes that they reset Aji III as
this way she will forget everything and
help him move on Min Q is devastated but
he knows that this is the only way later
that day Jia also hears the news
heartbroken she dresses up as Ashi 3 for
one last time the next time we see her
she stands in front of Min Q in his
house as snow falls outside he takes her
for a walk for one last time and returns
to the mansion they finally face each
other and Min Q tells her that the
things he showed her today are parts of
the everyday life that she gave give
back to him after 15 long years minky
then thanks her for being so many things
to him including his friend and his cure
and he apologizes again Jia struggles to
hold back tears as she expresses how
thankful and sorry she is too she only
hopes that he can be happy in the coming
days Min Q stares at her and as a tear
Falls he manages to calmly order Aji III
into operation mode after this he
announces that he's about to reset her
prompting Jia to remind him that all of
their memories will be permanently
deleted despite this Min Q agrees to
proceed but before he can press the
button he takes out his mother's
necklace and places it around Gia's neck
he then Embraces her and hits the button
before inputting his final message I
love you as Gia starts to count down to
the reset Min Q Su comes to his tears
and holds her tightly once she reaches
one she finally lets a tear fall back in
the lab the riolaji 3 reports that
minku's folder has been deleted that
night minku and Shia cry themselves to
sleep in their respective homes Jia
cries some that she falls ill the
following morning she's taken to the
hospital due to severe dehydration and
there we see that she is still wearing
minku's necklace as they move on with
their lives Jia moves to her hometown
with her grandma while Min Q prepares
for his wedding with real one day Min Q
gets on the train where he runs into a
familiar face she is none other than Gia
who Min Q believes is his ex-robot
however despite the two sitting next to
each other they don't utter a word Jia
is under strict orders to not react to
him while minku is skeptical if she's
really a robot or not you guys know that
feeling wasting no time Min Q calls
Professor Wong to ask how he came up
with ajith III's face Wong reveals that
he made the robot based on someone he
knew which resembles her face
personality habits and so on Min Q
wonders if it is possible to interact
with her and Wong says yes however he
asserts that it would be best if he
doesn't talk so that things don't get
awkward between the two despite the
advice Min Q follows her all the way to
her Grandma's shop and offers to chat
with her however she uses the excuse
that she is currently busy but being the
stubborn man that he is min Q is
determined to wait for her meanwhile Jia
hurries into the kitchen and takes off
the necklace around her neck and hides
it on a plate hours pass by but Min Q
still hasn't laughed so Jia is compelled
to interact with him she admits that she
tucked Dr Han's money four years ago to
become a character model but that's
about it Min Q tries to ask more but Gia
warns him to go away or else she will
call the police however Min Q cleverly
asks her grandma if she has an available
room and to Gia's horror the old lady
says yes and lets him stay for the night
for the next few days he bonds with
Grandma which also catches jia's
attention reminding her of her time with
him one evening Grandma asks Gia to pick
up goods from a warehouse but since it's
already dark she asks Min Kyu to
accompany her reluctantly Gia drives him
to the place during the journey they
look at each other's faces and remember
the past soon Jia starts opening up and
they chat all the way until they reach
the warehouse but as they are picking up
the required Goods unfortunately someone
locks the door unaware that two people
are still inside left with no choice the
couple is forced to spend the night
inside where they start bonding even
more the next day someone finally
unlocks the warehouse store and notices
the couple asleep next to each other
after waking up they return to Grandma's
store and help her with cooking at one
point Min Q almost spots the necklace
but before he can Jia again hides it the
next day Min Q again arrives at the
restaurant but learns that Gia has
already laughed sad he looks for her
everywhere until he finds her by the
pier seeing him Gia quickly covers the
necklace but it's too late because of
this Min Kyu starts reminiscing about
the last day when he was with Aji III
realizing that he was scammed he becomes
enraged but just before he can say
anything his allergy reappears and the
indicator shows red something which has
never happened before in the final scene
he falls to the ground in despair with
very little chances of survival
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching